it is the one year anniversary of the
donald trump january 6th riots in
washington dc tomorrow we'll talk about
joe biden's speech in which he
very heavily very strongly blames donald
trump for what happened a year ago
uh if you can imagine a more
brain-dead
ill-conceived
dangerous
action
than this
donald trump last night on the eve of
the anniversary of the trump riots put
out a statement calling for maggie
nation to quote rise up
think about what they did last year
and think about the insanity of putting
out such a statement once again let's
take a look
at uh the donald trump statement that he
put out yesterday
uh let's see if we can get zoomed in on
this so we can really take take a close
look at it statement by donald j trump
put out yesterday
the biden administration's response to
covid is getting worse every day joe
biden said quote there is no federal
solution to the pandemic but he then
federalized the distribution of
antibodies and red states are getting
the short end of the stick that's been
widely debunked by the way
although i agree that it was a really
bad idea for joe biden to run on fixing
covet and then say there's no federal
solution then why'd you run on it that
was a that was a mistake by joe biden
in my administration we respected the
role of governors to take care of their
own states and they could request
antibodies and therapeutics depending on
what they needed that's the way our
capital c country is supposed to run
now there's talk by the biden
administration again about closing
schools and even vaccine mandates for
school children remember this stuff is
really determined at the state level
so the fact that it's being discussed as
whether it makes sense is very very
different than taking power away from
governors okay
this is an outrage and here's the key
line and maga nation should rise up and
oppose this egregious federal government
overreach
this is now you might see this and say
david to normal people that wouldn't
move them to violence we are not dealing
with normal people
we are dealing with people here in
trumpists who last year
committed hundreds of crimes because
donald trump said let's go to the
capitol these are people who have spent
the last year
terrorizing school board meetings and
places where localities local
municipalities not the federal
government local officials are
discussing masking
vaccination
remote learning all these different
things
and now donald trump says to these
people you should rise up
rise up and oppose egregious federal
government overreach this is the exact
type of weaponization of ignorance and
radicalism that leads to real world
violence and trump is doing it again
on the eve of the january six riots
going on to say the democrats are so
incredibly mandate happy and there is a
discussion about a vaccine mandate for
school kids this year in detroit
and other democrat run places our
administration did what they said could
not be done vaccines in record time
remember that had nothing to do with
trump based on technology
under development for decades but we
never issued mandates and i never would
people should be able to choose how they
want to govern their own health the
federal government must be reined in and
give people freedom to decide whether
they want to be vaccinated or not
joe biden said he would never issue
mandates but he did it anyway like so
many other things so of course that's
pretty dishonest in the sense that
there's a you know joe biden has not
issued just a government mandate that
people must be vaccinated he has done
things in terms of employment he has
done things in terms of the department
of transportation etc you can say it's
good or bad you can say it's moral or
immoral it is not illegal and it is not
something joe biden said he wouldn't do
we can debate the effectiveness of it
but it is a lie to frame it in this way
so on the eve of the january 6th riot
anniversary
donald trump is doing exactly what he
did
364 days prior which is to tell lies
about
author supposedly authoritarian
democrats and encourage his followers to
rise up
to go there
and he's talking about rising up against
the federal government that is the exact
same thing that they did on january 6
2021. i'm hopeful that because
i mean listen a lot of these trumpists
now have seen more than 700 people
charged for their role last year in the
riots because there's a heavy police
presence in washington dc my hope is
there will be no repeat although some of
them would love to do it my hope is
there will be no repeat this year uh and
so far as of today that seems to be the
case i want to remind everybody tuesday
we will be doing the first david pakman
show viewer chess tournament of 2022
tuesday january 11
6 pm eastern
uh all you have to do for now
is join the david pakman show chess club
at davidpakman.com
chess you'll need a chess.com account
it's free i'm not selling you anything
other than a good time we've got some
great uh chess streamers who are going
to be participating uh grand master
benjamin feingold will be playing uh
international master eric rosen is going
to be joining us in streaming
women's feed master anna kremlin is
kremling is going to be participating in
streaming so it's going to be fun for
everybody you'll be matched up against
people of your level my level is very
low but it's still a really really good
time so just join the club free at
davidpakman.com chess and then we'll
have more information next week
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door ready to eat no
cooking no cleaning dishes saves you a
lot of time you can choose from over 50
hot and cold meal options there's
smoothies grain and noodle bowl soups
i'm a big soup guy many of you know that
i also really liked the vegan meatballs
with marinara noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below